hey everybody I'm happy to say that I'm
now on cameo.com you can find me at
cameo.com
Gregory badler you might be saying well
what's cameo.com it is a website
ostensibly for celebrities but you know
they let people like me in as well where
you can request
individualized short videos for yourself
or somebody
else who you care about who you think
might benefit from getting a video from
somebody and you tell me what it is that
you're looking for I shoot the video I
upload it and there you go I've actually
myself had some videos mostly from metal
people that uh were requested for me but
I've been doing some philosophy ones so
check it out the link is below but you
can also find it at cameo.com Gregory
badler